AND START IT LOOKS LIKE AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CAN MAKE IT
HERE SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
VOTE ON THESE ITEMS THAT BE
GREAT- IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
ONE AUTHOR HERE. IF YOU WANT
YOU CAN PRESENT FROM RIGHT
THERE THIS BETWEEN OURSELVES. I
MISS PETRIE-NORRIS HAS EIGHTY
REQUESTED CONCUR WITH SENATE
AMENDMENTS. AND IT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION. BAR ON
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT A. B. OUR ONE THREE TWO
SEVEN AB ONE THREE TWO SEVEN
WILL RATIONALIZE THE MEDI CAL
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR
LABORATORY SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA INSURANCE THAT OUR
LOCAL RAMPS ARE RECEIVING FAIR
AND EQUITABLE RATES AND ADD IN
ORDER TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA
JOBS AS WELL AS TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S FLOOD CAPACITY I
WHICH IS PARTICULARLY CRITICAL
AS WE KNOW IN. THIS CURRENT
MOMENT AND BY WAY OF BACKGROUND
EXISTING LINE ESTABLISHES A
MARKET BASED METHODOLOGY TO
DETERMINE THE FEE FOR SERVICE
AFTER MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES FOR CALIFORNIA THAT
SERVICES AT THIS ALSO INCLUDES
AN 80% CAP OF MEDICARE TAKEN
ALONG SIDES AND FEDERAL CHANGES
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. HI THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR LAB
SERVICESARE ACTUALLY UNDER
WATER FOR MANY CALIFORNIA LABS
YES WE NEED TO IMPLEMENT THIS
CHANGE IN ORDER Q. AS I SAID
ENSURE THAT WE ARE COMPENSATING
THEM FAIRLY AND EQUITABLY AND
THAT ENSURE THAT WE RETAIN
BLACK CASSIDY IN JOBS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WITH THAT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ADDRESS. THANK YOU WE HAVE.
PEOPLE ON THE PHONE IT OR IS
THAT JUST FOR QUESTIONS IF
THERE ARE ANY. WE HAVE A WE DID
HAVE A COUPLE OF WITNESSES MIND
OBSESSED BY BUT I'M NOT SURE IF
THEY'VE- BEEN ABLE TO JUMP ON
THE PHONE AND WE- PERHAPS HAVE
MOLLY READ SEND. FROM PLANNED
PARENTHOOD ON THE LINE. WE HAVE
OR CHRISTY FIVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CLINICAL LAB
ASSOCIATION DO WE HAVE ANYONE
ON THE PHONES. WE DO NOT HAVE
EITHER ONE OF THOSE TWO THAT'S
OKAY IF THERE'S A PROBLEM WE
CAN CABALLERO HAS DESTROYED.
ALL RIGHT. TOLD WHILE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MALI MALI HI YEAH. YOU
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. I'VE HAD
ANYWHERE VERY STARTED- MINE UP
AND MY PARENTS HAD A BELLY AT
THE CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN AND IT WILL INSURE
MEDICARE LAB RATES ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO ADDITIONAL CUTS
BEYOND MARKET VALUE- ALLOWED ME
TO NOT PROVIDERS LIKE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING CRITICAL SERVICES
INCLUDING ADULT LAB TAK FOR
ACTUALITY. YEAH I'VE AND ALLOW
US TO CONTINUE PROVIDING
CRITICAL CARE TO MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES HAPPY TO TALK
ABOUT THE FISCAL IMPACT ON
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATE
OTHERWISE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS ON EIGHTY
THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE'RE GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND BREAK REALLY QUICK
JUST TO- INSURE WE HAVE A
QUORUM. CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
GONZALEZ PRESENT BIGELOW
PRESIDENT POWER CAN. BLOOM
BONTA CALDERON YEAH CHAO DALLY
EIGHT EGGMAN BY GABRIEL GARCIA
PETRIE-NORRIS. QUIRK YEAH RIVAS
MOVE THE BALL. WE ARE MOTION
AND A SECOND I THINK THE
MEMBERS THAT JUST CAME MAN- WE
CAN SET AN AUDIENCE I. IF YOU
WANT TO SPEAK YOU CAN COME UP
HERE I'M SORRY. ALL RIGHT WITH
THAT THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND
A SECOND. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
SPEAKERS ON THE PHONE. ANY
OTHER SUPPORTERS ON THE PHONE.
AT THE FUNDS THERE. YES WHERE
THIRTY. YES HI I JUST GOT OUT
OF THE LINE THIS IS CHRISSY BOY
ARE WE ON AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN YES WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT. YES
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CLINICAL LABORATORY
THIRTIETH IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
SUPPORTERS. AND IF YOU ARE A
PART OF AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND THERE ARE NO MORE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
OPPONENTS. ANY OPPONENTS. ON
THE PHONES. BUT NOT ON THE
PHONE IF YOU WANT A MOMENT OF
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. IN
OPPOSITION. AND THERE ARE NONE
OF THE PHONE. THANK YOU A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JULIE EDITOR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE
IT RESULTS IN COSTS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE CURRENT FISCAL
PLAN- AND BECAUSE REMOVING THE
STATUTORY CAP ON REIMBURSEMENT
RATES WE FEEL IS MORE
APPROPRIATELY CONSIDERED
ALONGSIDE OTHER POLICY CHANGES
IN THE BUDGET PROCESS I WOULD
KNOW THAT ANNUAL COSTS ARE
BETWEEN TWO MILLION ONE MILLION
OF WHICH IS GENERAL FUND A TO
FOURTEEN POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS HALF OF WHICH WOULD BE
GENERAL FUND TO REMOVE THE
STATUTORY CAP ON REIMBURSEMENT
RATES THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
THAT GETS OUT IN I RATE AND A
ROLL CALL WITH MR DF NOT VOTING.
THANK OKAY. EIGHT NOW DID YOU
NOT WANT TO NOT VOTE ON THAT.
YOU CAN VOTE YES ABSOLUTELY
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE CONFUSION.
FINE BY CEDAR PANTS HERE- MR
SANTIAGO. MR SANTIAGO HAS AB
EIGHT TWENTY SIX IT'S TO
CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS-
IT ENJOYS A HIGH RECOMMENDATION
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
CALDERON A SECOND TIME IS
CARILLO. SURE NO I DON'T KNOW
WE'RE BACK AT. I THINK THE
MANAGER IN THE INTEREST OF THE
COMMITTEES TIME I WILL BE BRIEF
SIMPLY TO SAY THAT EIGHTY
EIGHTY SIX OR PROVIDE SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS- EMERGENCY-
FOOD ASSISTANCE AT ANY
HOUSEHOLD WITH TWO ADULTS OR AN
INDIVIDUAL AT THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS- WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES
WILL ALSO BE BRIEF. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT IF YOU'RE
WITNESSES- YOU HAVE A MOTION
AND SECOND IF THEY WANT TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS. OR SAY
ANYTHING LOOK AT THE PHONES.
MINISTROS CIVITELLA DIRECTOR
POLICY ADVOCACY WHICH HAS LEFT
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS IS STOP
APPROACH AND COULD SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL AND THE SPECTACULAR
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. HI MATT HI MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS INTERCHANGE
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS. ALSO
BECAUSE MIGRANTS ARMS BUT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY
OTHER COLORS IN SUPPORT. YOU
AREN'T PART OF AB TWO EIGHT SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. NO I
THINK YOU. ALL RIGHT I'M MORE
WORK. IS THERE ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION. ON THE FUNDS. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO. FOR A. B. IT. AND
THERE WAS NOBODY ON THE PHONE
THANK YOU A DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WE DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED
POSITION ON THIS MEASURE BUT
WOULD NOTE THAT IT MAY RESULT
IN GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURE
IN THE TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF GREATER. DEPENDING
ON THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO WOULD APPLY FOR AND RECEIVE
THESE BENEFITS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
MISTER SANTIAGO. RESPECTFUL
ENOUGH AND I BONE THANK YOU
MANAGER. THANK YOU. THAT GETS
OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING
AND MISTER DEPUTY HI. ALL RIGHT
WE WILL MOVE ON MISTER CALDERON
YOU'RE GONNA PRESENT FOR MR
RUSSELL YOU CAN PRESENT FROM
RIGHT THERE IF YOU WANT IT'S S.
B. FIFTY ONE- OTHER HEDGE IT IT.
IT STATES THE CHAIR DOES NOT
HAVE A RECOMMENDATION AND I'M
JUST INFO FOR. EXPLAIN WHY
AFTER THE PRESENTATION OF THE
BILL RIGHT. ACTION BY S. ANY
THAT. GREAT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I'LL BE BRIEF OR LONGER
IF YOU NEED ME TO BE WELL BUT
BASICALLY SB FIFTY ONE WITHOUT
INCREASING THE NET COST TO
TAXPAYERS WHO WOULD MAKE THE
CALIFORNIA COMPETES TAX CREDIT
MORE ATTRACTIVE TO LARGE
COMPANIES WILLING TO LOCATE
BUILDING EXPAND MEDIA
PRODUCTION INFRASTRUCTURE IN
CALIFORNIA AS LONG AS THEY
COMMIT TO CREATING AT LEAS
FIVE THOUSAND FULL TIME JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA EVERY YEAR GOING
FORWARD FOR AT LEAST TEN YEARS.
THIS BILL DOES NOT ADD ANYMORE
MONEY IT'S ALREADY- IT'S
ENCOMPASSED ALL WITHIN THE CAL
COMPETES TAX CREDIT MONEY
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN ALLOCATED
TO THE COCKING PIECE TAX CREDIT
IS JUST ADDING ANOTHER FACET
FOR ANYBODY THAT'S WILLING TO
MAKE A LARGER MORE SUBSTANTIAL
COMMITMENT TO THE CAP TO
CALIFORNIAN CREATING JOBS
BUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. NO THANK YOU IN MOTION BY
DOCTOR QUIRK IN A SECOND BY
MISS CARILLO ARE THERE
SPEAKERS. ON THE LINE. MADAM
OPERATOR FOR NONE. THANK YOU- I
GUESS THERE'S NO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION AS WELL THEN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION AT THIS TIME AND WOULD
NOTE THAT- GIVEN THE TAX CREDIT
REFUNDS ARE TO BE ALLOCATED
WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA COMPETES
PROGRAMS EXISTING ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY MILLION DOLLAR
ANNUAL ALLOCATION. AND IT IS
EXPECTED THAT GO THIS- INTENDS
TO ALLOCATE TAX CREDITS UP TO
THAT LIMIT THAT NO INCREASE IN
PROGRAM COST IS EXPECTED
HOWEVER WE WOULD KNOW THAT IT'S
POSSIBLE THERE WOULD BE SOME
ACCELERATION IN TAX CREDIT
USAGE WHICH COULD RESULT IN ONE
TIME REVENUE LOSSES IN THE NEAR
TERM- THE MAGNITUDE WOULD
DEPEND ON THE AMOUNT OF
REFUNDABLE TAX CREDITS
ALLOCATED. AND THE CREDIT USAGE
PATTERN OF WHATEVER TAXPAYERS
ARE DIVIDED CREDIT. ALLOCATION
AS A RESULT OF THIS BILL. GO
THIS IS STATED IT WOULD NOT
INCREASE ITS ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS AND LIKEWISE THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD HAS ALSO
INDICATED IT WOULD NOT
INCREASE- IT'S ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS THANK YOU. WITH THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ALL RIGHT IN FULL
DISCLOSURE- I DO NOT PLAN I
PLAN TO RECUSE MYSELF FROM THIS
VOTE- I EIGHTY IN THE MEDIA
THAT N. N. CONVERSATIONS AT
DIFFERENT POINTS THIS IS BEEN
DESCRIBED AS THE NETFLIX BILL
ALTHOUGH IT IS I WILL NOTE THAT
IT IS AVAILABLE TO ANYBODY IN
CALIFORNIA BUT IT HAS BEEN
DESCRIBED AS THAT. AND NETFLIX
I THINK HAS- SUGGESTED THAT
THEY WOULD APPLY FOR IT MY
DAUGHTER IS STARTING A JOB IN
PRODUCTION AT NETFLIX NEXTWEEK
I DON'T WANT THERE TO BE ANY
SENSE OF IMPROPRIETY OBVIOUSLY
MY DAUGHTER ALTHOUGH NOT
INDEPENDENT OF MINE IS STILL ON
MY HEALTH CARE SEVEN
INDEPENDENCE OF CAUTION
ALTHOUGH NO LEGAL REQUIREMENT
I'M RECUSING MYSELF FROM THIS
VOTE AND FULL DISCLOSURE AND
THAT IS WHY. WITH THAT. NO MORE
DISCUSSION THAT GETS OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL WITH MR DE FOT HI.
AND MR FONG NOT VOTING AND OF
COURSE MYSELF MCCARTY. ALL
RIGHT THAT CONCLUDES OUR.